you know I wasn't really planning on
talking about this because we're right
in the middle of a major release for our
game engine Hazel and uh it feels a
little bit weird talking about you know
the controversies of
another game engine but you guys really
wanted me to talk about it and I could
honestly use a bit of a break from
programming and setting up automated
testing which is what I'm doing at the
moment and one of my goals with this
channel is just to be a little bit more
chill a little bit more you know like
let's talk about stuff so here goes I'm
going to talk about unity and their new
pricing situation and what my thoughts
are about that as well as what Hazel's
plan for monetization and pricing will
be in the future okay
hahaha
Where Do We Begin
so about a week ago I guess
um Unity announced that they would be
changing their pricing model their
existing pricing model to essentially
introduce some kind of royalty fee now
the fact that they're effectively trying
to get more money is really no surprise
the company has been unprofitable for
like for like ever and in their latest
like quarterly earnings call they cited
a strong quarter because they lost 192
million dollars instead of like around
250. so the point is Unity as a as a
company is still very much in the
negative they're making like half a
billion dollars per quarter which sounds
great but then their operating costs are
around 700. I kind of want to talk about
that
um because that just blows my mind a few
years ago before I had any interest in
unity's like business moves and their
financial situation I would have thought
that Unity was a profitable company
because their product is extremely
popular
and seemingly not like that big of an
operation or like one would think that
it's not like you know the most complex
piece of software in the world like you
know you could look at something like
Adobe and their whole Suite of tools and
be like yeah that's probably a large
software company but like Unity like
yeah it's a game engine game managers
are complicated but you know Unity is
not like the most complicated game
engine in the world right like it should
be you wouldn't expect anything huge
yeah up until I discovered that they
have 7 700 employees why what's going on
I think EA has about 10 000 worldwide
and EA is a billion dollar company who
not only makes their own game engine
which in terms of technology is vastly
superior to Unity I should know I worked
on frostbite but then apart from the
engine they make all the games and they
are profitable they had two billion
dollars of Revenue last quarter last
year with a net income of 402 million
dollars that's a profit margin of 20.8
percent so a net income of 402 million
dollars and yet unities is a is is minus
192 million okay it's not actually 10
000 employees is twelve thousand nine
hundred sure but my point still stands
why does unity have so many employees
what do they do perhaps a better
comparison would be epic games right
they have 3700 employees 3 700 epic
games 7 700 Unity I don't know what's
going on I I don't know I don't know why
you Unity needs that many people oh
honestly I don't even know where to
start with this video I've got so much
to say Let Me Maybe Just make a quick
little disclaimer though that these are
my thoughts I had this is not a fact
checked video I will be Googling things
as I go along because I don't want to
get numbers wildly wrong but these are
these are more or less my thoughts and
as I mentioned like we're in the middle
of a serious like hazel release at the
moment so I'm not not I'm not taking
time to research this this is literally
my lunch break right now I thought I
would just record a little video okay so
I suppose we should start with the
actual pricing situation since that's
what we're kind of talking about what
has unity done they want to make more
money as we just talked about their huge
amount of employees their negative
financial situation you know I'm sure
they don't just spend money on it
employees and staff obviously they have
Acquisitions like WETA which we should
maybe talk about that because I don't
understand why they did that I don't
think they deserve weather to be
completely honest but anyway what a
passionate lunch break in an effort to
make more money they have decided to
introduce this thing called a runtime
fee and this runtime fee is essentially
ranges from around 2 20 cents per
install of a Unity product I imagine
like a game that a studio or a developer
has shipped every time that game gets
installed Unity gets 20 cents of like a
royalty fee now that's like the highest
amount and that's only if you cross some
kind of threshold of how much revenue
you've earned in the last 12 months and
also an install count kind of threshold
as well now if you have a different
edition of unity Unity Pro or Unity
Enterprise that fee drops a bit to 15
cents and 12 and a half cents per
install respectively and then drops even
further as you as you cross over a
hundred thousand installs and Beyond now
this just to be clear on paper the cost
to the developer
is not actually that high and since
there is a revenue threshold this
obviously means that games that are for
example free to play or extremely like
cheap like if I sell a game for a dollar
that doesn't mean most likely that I pay
20 cents 20 to Unity because if I'm
reading this right I wouldn't I mean if
I had Unity personal unity plus I guess
I would be but if I had a Unity Pro
which we can talk about later then I'd
be paying like you know for a million
installs let's just say because they're
so cheap and I'm making a million
dollars only from from a million
installs and of course there's like you
know cuts from whatever platform you're
doing it on so it's not going to be a
million dollars but let's just say it is
three cents per install so from that
kind of dollar you know I'm potentially
getting three cents or even two cents
per install if I have Unity Pro and I'll
put the table up obviously so you guys
can see so that itself uh is that I mean
that's three or two percent from that
and it's a very cheap game if it's a
more expensive game you know these
things still kind of you know this this
still kind of applies like you're still
paying with unity Pro 15 install if you
have less than a hundred thousand
installs by the way I should mention
this per month but you know what's
annoying as I sit here and read this
table and also try to explain to you
guys that it's actually not that bad the
fee itself it's the fact that like I
have to read this table I have to think
about this it's per month I have to
think about how these fees are
calculated which will get to the
calculating of this later as well it's
just very very confusing
like it's just not really that obvious
how much money I'll be paying and also
that's gonna vary per month because if I
if I get you know 50 000 installs one
month and all these installs really
makes me think of mobile games which
makes sense because Unity is obviously
kind of targeting that that a lot but
you know 50 000 installs one month one
maybe 15 cents seven and a half cents
per install if it's if it's above 100
like this is all very very confusing but
I guess what I'm trying to say in
unity's defense and this by the way is
probably going to be the only thing I
say in unity's defense so if you're a
fan of unity just
cherish this part of the video uh the
end result like the fee you will be
paying is probably going to be quite low
and if we compare this to another
serious engine Unreal Engine who just
takes five percent if you are above a
million dollars uh this is likely going
to be cheaper likely
um I'm sure there are scenarios in which
this will be more expensive but I have a
feeling just from looking at this table
that it will be cheaper now compared to
unreals five percent this is infinitely
more complex five percent of just your
money makes a lot of sense there's no
but how much money are you making from
these games or how much money are you
selling them for you know is this in-app
purchases that might be like 99 Cents
because again mobile games right mobile
games are not usually huge you know for
a desktop game there's seventy dollars
you might look at this and be like yeah
20 cents per install whatever right but
obviously for mobile games it might be
1.99 99 Cents they might have in-app
purchases like this is all getting a
little bit fuzzy as to how much money
I'm going to be spending on this versus
just to pay it's five percent man like
I'm paying five percent of whatever my
game makes I'm paying for my for the for
the base set of technology that I'm
using to make that the game which again
seems super Fair because because five
percent is not that much especially
considering that if you were to go out
and invest in Engineers to build that
technology yourself you would be you'd
be spending much more money than five
percent of the game that you you are
making unless potentially you're a
multi-billion dollar AAA company if you
make more money well it's a percentage
it's five percent so it scales if you
make less money it's a percentage it's
five percent it scales it makes a lot
more sense than this garbage now hard to
understand aside how do we measure
installs and more importantly users
don't pay per install they they buy the
game and then they can install it on
multiple computers they can uninstall it
they might be running out of disk space
I need to uninstall it I need to install
it again uh what if I want to install it
what if I have three computers I have
like a a work computer I have a home
computer and I have a laptop for
traveling I like this game I want to
install it you know that's three times
potentially the way that the gaming
Market works is you don't pay to install
stuff on your device you buy a copy of
the game it's stored in your account you
pay once for it and then you obviously
install it on whatever device you want
so there's this disconnect immediately
between how developers make money and
how developers have to pay Unity because
if developers make money one single time
during one transaction assuming this
isn't like some recurring payment for an
in-app purchase for a mobile game or
whatever let's just go with a flat kind
of One Singular transaction then why are
they paying Unity per install
that is kind of weird and of course
users could reinstall the game many many
times and maliciously also potentially
create scripts as people have pointed
out that just download and install the
game over and over again in an effort to
attack and hurt the developer now here's
the kicker Unity have come out and said
that oh yeah yeah don't worry reinstalls
like
they're not counted fraud
yeah like me I reach out to us you know
if you've got fraud but don't worry
we're not going to charge you for that
and also come to think of it how many
times have these games been installed
how do I know how many times my game has
been installed well Unity apparently
have some kind of proprietary
installation tracking software that is
essentially a black box from what I
understand correct me if I'm wrong but
from what I understand it's a black box
of proprietary Tech and tracking that
will tell Unity how many times your game
has been installed by users and the
consensus really seems to be kind of
like just trust me bro like just Uni's
gonna call you out one day and be like
mate
mate I'm so proud of your game you know
I'm so glad you made it with unity you
know it's amazing to see your success oh
thanks Unity we just wanted to
congratulate you on Crossing one million
installs like that must be such a good
feeling you're so successful
congratulations also here's the here's
the invoice and then the developer would
be like what
we made like a hundred thousand dollars
off of this like I'm pretty sure that
we're not that popular again one million
installs you guys are doing so great
thanks again for using unity and uh this
is due at the end of the month like what
is this proprietary installation garbage
no wonder they need so many Engineers
because instead of like whose idea is
that whose idea is it to come along and
be like you know what you know what we
should be doing as a game engine let's
invest engineering resources in creating
a proprietary installation tracker so
that we can figure out a way to make
money and probably the most Shady way
possible instead of just having a flat
like I don't know what makes sense like
well how about five percent of whatever
you make because like that's what
everyone else does that's literally
Revenue Split For Everything YouTube
AdSense steam Store App Store like
everything no no no no no we're gonna do
a per install thing that's gonna hide
the real numbers from you the method
that we use to deduce those numbers is
also not really going to be shared
you're gonna have to trust us so now a
technology that we wrote to measure how
much money you owe us like what's going
on and and to make matters worse this
isn't just like a new thing going
forward this is a thing that is applying
to all games as far as I understand like
it's a retrofit thing it's happening
from the 1st of January 2024 to every
current Unity title right is it am I
right in saying that I I don't know it
almost sounds unbelievable because that
means that the terms of service that you
signed the pricing that you agreed to
pretty much contractually here at this
point has been Rewritten in fact it's
been Rewritten so hard that they just
nuked the GitHub repository that had
these terms of service this is literally
Darth Vader being like I have altered
the rules pray I don't alter them
further that is that is the summary of
this entire situation and that is why I
imagine people are so upset because what
the heck how can you just go ahead and
do this and what happens if further down
the road you decide to do this again
right because apparently they're back
pedaling a little bit or at least being
like we've taken off what's on board
like yes we we're aware of the backlash
like stay with us as we negotiate to
maybe come up with a a different
solution potentially as of me recording
this video they haven't released any
additional solution or like whatever
their next steps are but they're
considering it but again what happens if
they consider it what happens if they go
harder or change something and can I
just point out that again if you have
Unity Pro that's like two thousand
dollars per year per seat
so like for a three-person team you're
paying six thousand US dollars per year
and then also this install fee which is
a little bit minimized like it's 15
cents the base levels of 20. but can I
just point out how this Unity Pro
situation is literally so much more
expensive than adobe's entire Suite of
applications like yes I get that a game
engine is more Tech and in a way it's
almost like the entire Suite in one
massive application but that still feels
crazy to me considering if you release
stuff you also pay a royalty especially
when what seems to be unity's primary
competitor is Unreal Engine which is
completely free to use didn't used to be
that way it used to be 20 a month so
they're actually lowering their prices
and then just a five percent easy to
understand royalty if you make above a
million dollars that's it oh and the
source code is available the main source
development repository for the engine is
available for free as well now while
we're on the topic of on rail being
you're his biggest competitor I don't
understand why that is like yes people
always compare Unreal Engine and unity
unreal and unity and then there's like
Godot which used to be in the background
but now it's rising from the ashes and
like the thing is I like Godot and unity
yeah I absolutely see them as
competitors but I don't quite understand
why Unreal Engine keeps getting in this
and why Unity itself and their
leadership seem to actively be chasing
Unreal Engine and trying to provide what
we call in the industry I guess an HD
engine meaning that like an engine that
is capable of High Fidelity high quality
graphics for the latest generation of
consoles and high-end PC games as well I
honestly do not think Unity should be
competing in that space first of all
epic games has just completely I don't
know how to put this delicately like
they have taken the lead so hard in the
High Fidelity serious game development
space that I think it might actually
just be too late for Unity to try and
reach that level unless something
happens to epic games and the thing is
it's not just like high-end 3D games
that Unreal Engine does so well it's the
whole AAA experience it's the whole we
have millions of dollars of budget to
spend on a big game we're gonna have
really serious asset pipelines and
really high quality assets we're going
to have a team of Engineers that can
actually take that engine and extend it
like we are a AAA production house and
we want to use the best technology
available on the planet to build this
huge like I don't know 100 million
dollar game like in that space Unreal
Engine is King now I just want to say as
a disclaimer because I always feel like
I have to mention things otherwise some
people will take what I say literally
Unreal Engine is not perfect nothing in
this entire planet is perfect I've got
news for you buddy nothing is perfect
there is no perfect engine there is no
perfect anything so of course Unreal
Engine has problems of course for
frostbite has problems even though those
are kind of designed to be you know AAA
engines and of course he already has
problems hence this video but the point
is why is Unity trying to compete with
that when well actually there's
something Unity is good at isn't it
something that Unreal Engine apparently
can't do very well but Unity can
what was that again oh yes mobile and 2D
huge markets especially mobile so if
Unity is a better choice for mobile
games and for 2D games than Unreal
Engine and mobile makes up a huge
percentage of unity's Revenue in their
market share and to make matters even
better for those kinds of I guess
demographics we'll say of developers not
even demographics but just the types of
teams that might build those games Unity
is very easy to use it's much easier to
use it's much more accessible in that
sense compared to Unreal Engine which is
supposed to be AAA engine like it's just
easy it's just easier like it's faster
to get going it's easier to understand
the technology is significantly worse
but that's fine for mobile and for 2D
games in fact I'm pretty sure the
technology is better for that seems to
be working better anyway why don't they
focus on that why do they have to do
things like acquire wetter an amazing
visual effects Studio that Peter Jax
made for the Lord of the Rings that is
obviously very high fidelity Graphics
why because unreal Andre doing like
Mandalorian and all that kind of virtual
production stuff and they're making more
like photorealistic and CG kind of tools
for like offline use and for visual
effects and for the film industry like
but you've got a good thing going with
mobile and 2D you're making money from
that why do you need over 7000 employees
to try and just do everything when you
have a plan that's working so well so I
don't even know I don't even know if
it's a plan or if it's just happened and
then they're like no no but Unreal
Engine but Unreal Engine these guys are
obsessed with Unreal Engine I don't know
what's going on like I truly do not this
is the beginning of me looking into this
stuff like I might be wrong on so many
fronts and that's okay because I'm not
this is not a news channel like this is
not a news channel this is a channel
puts up whatever video he wants channel
so forgive me if I'm wrong but that is
just unbelievable to me the
mismanagement that seems to be happening
with unity and then people are saying
yes the CEO who used to be xea what do
you expect but then like it begs the
question of like well maybe actually EA
was bad because of him like maybe he's
the problem them since he says he seems
to be doing this to every company but
anyway I don't want to talk too much
about like that per se because honestly
I just don't understand it deep enough
but it's just Madness how their
leadership seems to be going for things
that I do not think they should be going
for and meanwhile like if we look at
Epic Games leadership Tim Sweeney like
the CEO of epic games like is first of
all very present I mean he built this
thing right like he knows stuff about
game engines he's very like present I
guess I would say in the community
especially compared to you know Unity
CEO and Leadership and just looking at
how Unreal Engine have progressed down
from lowering their prices you know if
you if you love something set it free
that whole thing are they made Unreal
Engine free how their Source codes
available how they decided oh I don't
know what's a good idea maybe we should
make a game with our game engine like
wouldn't that be a good idea oh what is
the most popular game in the planet and
we have billions of dollars which we can
then use and to top it off it's a
private company this isn't like some
kind of this is you this isn't Unity
going public and then having this
mandate This legal obligation basically
to make money for the investors they
have to make money their business that's
what they do no no epic games is private
epic games can do whatever they want I
mean epic games designed by tencent and
there might be some like they might want
them to do something like make money but
still it seems to be a different story
and even if they were a publicly traded
company like they still made fortnite
they still made billions they're still
seemingly profitable I couldn't imagine
them not being profitable considering
they make so much more money and they
have less than half the employees and
bear Tech is just amazingly better they
have done things that no other game
engine has done and on this entire
planet like they have pushed like with
nanite and with Lumen and you know the
the whole ecosystem of what they've done
with those systems you know and extended
that into the rest of the engine like
that is a tremendous amount of effort
anyway I could I I just don't know I
just don't know why Unity is is going
down that road when they could be the
premium engine for independent
developers who want to make more basic
games for all platforms and both Indie
and high-end developers who want to make
mobile games or 2D games like that could
be their Market they could excel at that
and yet they're trying to do everything
and clearly they're probably now
realizing that you can't just throw
engineers at stuff you can't just throw
more employees at everything and stuff
will work out you actually have to
manage those employees and you have to
have good leadership so I don't know
that's kind of those are my thoughts
um this has been this is kind of
dragging on
um so I I don't want to talk about hazel
my game engine too much in this video I
did promise I would talk about like the
plan for the monetization and pricing I
will discuss that in depth in another
video but the gist is basically this
when Hazel has more features and is
slightly more ready for actual like game
development outside of like a this is a
an in-development engine we are planning
to release like the game engine itself
which means the binaries for it so you
can download it install it and use it
for free that's going to be 100 free you
can use Hazel to make whatever game you
want and you can sell that game and
distribute that game and there will be
no royalty fees it will be completely
free for you but
but if you would like the source code of
the game engine along with all of like
the Shader code and you want to tweak
stuff and you want to maybe extend the
engine or learn from the source code or
you just want access to our internal
like development repository which
contains all of the kind of features
that aren't done yet versions of the
engine that might be a bit more bleeding
edge but just haven't been properly QA
tested and released because you want to
stay more involved or if you simply want
to support the team that's going to cost
ten dollars 10 US dollars per month on
patreon that is the deal that is our
transparent pricing it's completely free
to use to ship games like Godot would be
but because we need to make money ten
dollars per month if you want access to
the source code and the development
repository so that is our plan that is
our master plan we are not a public
company we are a profitable company and
so I don't intend that these prices will
ever really change or go up or anything
I can't promise that for the rest of my
life because I don't know what will
happen but at the moment it certainly
seems that way so thank you for watching
if you would like to support Hazel right
now patreon.com the channel that's how
you can support us we are trying to make
it into a serious engine we'll be
starting work on an actual premium
titled like you know game that we are
planning to release on Steam for PC on
all platforms next year so buy van by
the time we start working on that game
we intend to hopefully next year have
that binary free release ready to go so
you guys can use it for free and make
games for free if you want thank you all
for watching what are your thoughts on
this whole Unity pricing situation do
you agree with me that Unity maybe
shouldn't be chasing after unreal and
they should I don't know just focus on
what they're good at and also can
someone please explain to me why they
have that many employees like please I
just don't I just don't understand that
anyway drop the comments below love you
guys see you next time goodbye